lawmakers working to keep coronavirus
benefits have a plan
to extend a friday to extend a friday
deadline and house and senate leaders
are considering a 908 billion dollar
spending package to help small
businesses
unemployed workers and state and local
governments they want to attach
that 908 billion dollars to a larger
spending bill that will keep the
government operating in the new year
now the house plans to vote tomorrow to
keep the government running
for one more week giving negotiators
more time and the senate is expected to
follow suit
democratic senator joe manchin of west
virginia is
part of that bipartisan group promoting
that coronavirus relief plan he joins us
from capitol hill senator good morning
thank you for being with us first
question good morning dee first question
do you have the votes to pass this
oh i sure do think so this is failure is
not an option anthony we just can't fail
there's too much at stake here people
running out of their life lines which
end
and are eliminated into december we all
know that so
food assistance shelter the basic
necessities of life
are something that we have to continue
to help people businesses are falling
through the cracks
because they've basically been ordered
to close or shutter down
or basically no indoor dining
restaurants venues so many people are
hurting so badly
and it's been said by both sides anthony
if you hear both sides talking
if we don't invest this is an emergency
relief covert package
remember the word emergency this is not
a do-all end-all
but if we don't do something now the 908
billion dollars that we're coming
together
on democrats and republicans working
bipartisan by
camera with the problem solvers in the
house all of us working together if we
don't do this
they've said this is much more important
and probably is more effective
than the two trillion dollars it might
take in february or march to pull us out
of a hole you've acknowledged it's it's
not enough there will need to be more
but you correct
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
president trump neither have endorsed
this
have you spoken to either of them are
you expecting them to come on board
well i think they both give encouraging
signs that something needs to be done
and they're looking and they're very
encouraging i heard that leader mitch
mcconnell
has said that basically bipartisan a
deal
can be done and that's very encouraging
because we are prepared to do a deal
you'll see what we call section by
section be
rolled out this afternoon probably in
the three four o'clock range
the people been drafting the staff's
been working around the clock
and we just have a couple more things
we're waiting on more information but
we'll get 90 percent of it out today
so the american public can see how we
want to roll this out well senator
manchin i know you said you're
optimistic and a lot of people are
counting on this
but and christmas break is coming up if
it's not done should christmas break be
delayed when you have so many people who
are in pain are just waiting and hoping
on you guys to
get this done i don't know how i don't
know how any senator could go home or
any congress person could return home
not making every effort how can you look
at people that will be displaced
be evicted or in hunger lines people
that you've never seen in long lines for
food assistance
all the things that were hurting
businesses that closed down that might
not ever open back
up i don't know how you can go home and
say well i'm sorry we had to come home
for christmas vacation
well they're going to say take a
vacation don't even go back that's what
i would say
will direct cash payments be included in
this because there's
a bipartisan push both like from josh
holding on the right bernie sanders on
the left no
sure anything i understand that remember
i used the word emergency
yeah yeah we had a hard time having our
republicans move
off the 500 billion and then we've had a
hard time for democrats to come down
below
1.2 yeah everyone has moved in an area
says can we just
least meet the emergency needs of
america and if you look at everything
that is going to be eliminated as of
december 31st
that's where your priorities must be for
an emergency relief package
that's what we've done and i and joe
biden said this is a down payment
uh we're president joe biden coming in
we're he'll come back and
lay out a new plan of what he thinks it
takes to have this economy recover and
stay on a course
vaccines are coming out people's spirits
will be lifted
we just got to get through a very
difficult first quarter the most
challenging we've ever faced
well you know the congress has only
passed one stimulus bill so far and
everybody agrees people are hurting
why is this so difficult why haven't why
hasn't congress done more at this point
without finger pointing it must be very
frustrating to you too
oh my it's so frustrating but i think
what's happened gail
is people are looking at all the stock
markets are soaring unemployment has
come down
some what they're not talking about is
still the unemployed and underemployed
people that went back to work that can't
make their full paycheck because the
economy is not there if they worked in
the restaurant entertainment or any of
these venues
so this is a tremendous problem that we
have people being evicted
we know the landlord's trying to play
their mortgage payment when a person is
evicted there's no money
we're trying to address every uh thing
that we need to be addressed today that
we think that could have been done
better the first time
we're learning from that and trying to
correct those mistakes i can tell you
this i am so proud of the democrats and
republicans
we're all friends we've always been
friends we just don't always sit down
and work together
for the last three weeks we've been
hooked to the hip probably four to five
six hours a day
back and forth on zooms and and it's
encouraging it really is and a bicameral
too
from our house members have been so
constructive all right senator joe
manchin thank you very much for being
with us this morning we hope this deal
gets done
yes let's remember that word friends yes
let's remember that f word friends
that's right kale i can't wait to see
you all in person again yeah
for sure thank you